believe believe believe believe we
believe between
hello believe nation today we're going
to talk about the power of belief and as
always guys as you're watching if you
hear something that really inspires you
please leave it down the comments below
put quotes around it as well so other
people can be inspired and when you
write it down it's much more likely to
sink in for yourself as well enjoy I
[Music]
want you to look at something right now
thank you some major goal you want or
maybe it's one you already working on
and you have experienced a lot of
setbacks a lot of defeats you've
experienced a lot of disappointment
maybe you've already given up and maybe
you just need a little far little
encouragement to get back in the game
again here's what I want you to look at
they're winners they're losers and there
are people who have not discovered how
to win and all they need is some
coaching all they need is some help and
assistance just a little support all
they need is some insight or different
strategy a plan of action to make some
adjustments that will open up the key to
a whole new future for them that will
give them access to the unlimited power
that they have within themselves that's
all that they need so what I want you to
do is think about something you want for
you that's real for you that's important
for you that will give your life some
special meaning and power and I don't
even want you to say I can do that I
don't want you to assume that see five
years ago when I started out in this
area I would not have been able to make
the mental leap that I would be up to
where I am right now I don't want you to
begin to just psych yourself out no no I
want you to be able to say something to
yourself that will enable you to
maintain a level of integrity with
so that when you say this even when you
face tremendous setbacks it it will be a
benchmark to keep you in the game to
keep you moving forward and
experimenting and readjusting your
strategy and your plan of action
continuously looking for ways to win so
what is that something when you got an
idea you want to move on you might not
have the money you might not have the
education you might not have the support
or resources you need what is that
something that can keep us going that
will enable us to act on our dream
what's one of those keys that will begin
to help us to discover the secrets to
our dream here's what I want you to
repeat after me please with power and
conviction say it's possible that's all
I want you to do when you look at your
dream you say to yourself every day it's
possible yes say that every day to
yourself it's possible because what does
that do see it begins to change your
belief system see the way in which we
operate ladies and gentlemen it's a
manifestation of what we believe what's
possible for us whatever you've done up
to this point all that it really is is a
duplication it's a reproduction of what
you believe subconsciously that you
deserve and what's possible for your
life before in April 1954 the common
belief the universal belief because it
had been tried again and again and again
and people have failed the belief was
that man was not physically capable of
breaking the four-minute barrier that he
could not la mile in less than four
minutes that was the belief on the
planet it had never been done but here's
what happened ladies and gentlemen Roger
Bannister came along and he wrote the
four-minute barrier now here's what's
significant about that since that time
off to this day over 20,000 people have
done it including high school kids
what change 20,000 people what changed
here's what happened when they got on
the track they knew it had been done and
because they knew it had been done there
was a new belief about this barrier
about this goal that was unreachable and
those 20,000 people got an a' raised
believe me knowing in the heart that
someone had done it that it's possible
that they could do it and i'm saying
that if you know anybody that had some
goal some dreams something they wanted
to do and they did it denied thing that
you know in your heart that if someone
has done it then you can do it it's
possible and that if someone can make
that dream become a reality that it's
it's possible that you can make your
dream become reality first day I went to
school I was in a classroom by the time
I was a you know six years old didn't go
to school - I was 6 years old cause I
lived my grandmother here time sure but
she had taught me how to read read the
Bible Bible stories so I went into the
classroom knowing Nicodemus Shadrach
Meshach and Abednego I could spell all
of those words I thought I was you know
I was preaching to the to my
kindergarten teacher at Dover she's like
who is the director so I was never
placed in an environment where I was
ever made to feel inferior I always felt
like I'm the smartest kid in this room
and because I would never place them and
it never put in a position where I was
made to feel less than I didn't grow up
feeling less than you know and the rest
as they say is history and the
resonances are true and it's all about
what you believe you know I say this too
when I do something on my network now
call life class the fundamental key to
success is what you believe is true for
yourself not what you want not what your
desire is what do you believe you know
you can say I wanted I want to be the
most successful person in the world
but if you believe that there's a glass
ceiling and you're going to have a hard
time kicking through that glass ceiling
we were defined by the glass ceiling and
the great beauty and gift of my life is
that I was never defined by the box that
other people tried to put me in stricken
that all back to starve your career a
man with a dream you know training the
gym day-in day-out somebody said to you
you'll have or you'll be as successful
as you are now what have you had said
back then I believe you that's what I
said because I did believe as I believed
in what I had very few people who told
me that I had a small small small group
of people that will tell me something
like that order than that it was just me
telling myself yeah so if someone came
up to me and told me that all the way
back then I'd say you're damn right one
of the things that's so fascinating to
me is that Amazon or Jeff Bezos have
pursued what might be described as a
very asset heavy business model they're
buying airplanes they want only entire
supply chain from beginning to end and
Alibaba has effectively an asset like
business it is very much in terms of the
retail piece of this the opposite you
don't want to own the warehouses you
don't want to own the logistics
companies how do you think about that is
Jeff Bezos right or you right and is
there is there going to be a meeting in
the middle I hope both are right and
because the world can never have a one
bottle if the world has only one correct
a model there was too boring
right we need to have all kinds of
models and the people who did the bottle
should believe in the model and I
believe what I do right the difference
between Amazon and us everything is more
like an empire everything they should
control themselves buy and sell and our
philosophy is that we want to be an
ecosystem our philosophy is to empower
others to sell empower others to sit to
service empower make sure the other
people are more powerful than us making
sure with our technology our innovation
our
haughtiness I was 10 very small business
sellers they can compete with Microsoft
IBM our philosophy is that we rethink
using Internet technology we can make
every company become amateur yeah I
think if you don't actually believe what
you're doing is really important if you
don't derive satisfaction from what
you're doing then you will not be able
to sustain all of the bad things that
happen an incredibly long period of time
that the bad things happen over and so
the only motivation that I have seen
work for people over a long period of
time is enjoyment and what they're doing
and an intense belief it matters and
ideally liking the people that they go
to work with every day um but the I
think the reason is that a lot of people
and by the way it's totally cool when
people start off saying well I want to
make money or I want to be famous I
think a lot of people start that way and
they don't like to admit it but pretty
quickly or least in the first few years
I think a lot of people find a deeper
mission for why they do what they do and
that drives them then for the rest of
the time they work what you represent
now for all those kids out there trying
to make it whatever field it is whether
it's music or something else what words
do you have for them in terms of how you
live your life and you've made it to
this point because you're not supposed
to supposed to be here right now now
what advice you have for them in terms
of their lives in their journey lace up
wait what does lace up mean for say it
you know it's the casual person it might
be seeing you for the first time on the
show what is lace up I mean I mean it
means what you wanted to read but to me
in a day and age like this and these put
both feet on that ground
lace up you're ready to face the world
go out there take it on and and you know
turn a grain of sand into a diamond
you know I'm saying yeah I think they
love that answer right there
they're definitely laced and that's what
it's about man you know what it's about
it's about believing in something you
know what I'm saying like having faith
in something man like that's what it is
like we're not trying to hear some we're
not trying to hear some you know
president in a suit who you know can't
even live his own life you know like
because he's so worried about public for
such a week we can't relate to that you
know I'm saying like they want to see
someone doing what they're doing living
how they're living coming from where
they're coming from
and like making something better of
themselves and just sitting on the rest
you know I'm saying like that's why
that's why they're screaming they like
big because they see that mouthing I'm
and that's what I'm coming with on this
island it's going to be the People's
Champ yeah you know name like I don't I
don't want to hear some Reverend tell me
I have to believe in organized religion
I don't want to hear some president
something we're going to do we're not
going to do because they never do it I
don't want to hear some teacher put a
limit on where my education could take
me you know I'm saying like they want to
teach me to you know go and fix lights
in the house but you don't want to tell
me that I can take my own career into my
own hands and be an entrepreneur and
come up with something like this they
didn't teach you you could do this yeah
I'm just I'm just not I'm not scared man
I'm ready to step up and be a leader for
this generation to be a voice for the
generation and all these people can act
like to talk up for these kids but it's
just an act like I'm still one of those
kids man like this means the world to me
and that's that's what this album is
about and I just know I just know things
are going to change man it's I feel it I
feel it I believe in like if you want to
be a fireman go and do it you want to be
a ballet dancer than go and be a ballet
dancer
today I believe in yourself and no one
else will believe in you and yes it's an
important thing it's so important for me
to people to understand that but I want
to be an inspiration hopefully and
kind of nine-hour tensions in our and I
want it I want to be a role model and I
think now I'm in the kind of Lima to go
it's okay and it's a special people that
I believe and others that have something
magical and it's something that you can
turn into a positive and not let it lead
you away and there'll always be someone
that says you can't do it they'd always
see someone a sense I don't they need to
do then always be someone that says I do
believe in it and they always tell me
that you can do it and that security has
to focus on how much them to transmit me
down which they do when they say you
know every family you thought I want to
burn my ears I say his last enough my
name is Alex Parrish protecting our
country had always been my dream
wonderboy was my first obviously I knew
I had to go in to this room and read
these lines in front of all these people
but I was so nervous before I went in so
I went to the bathroom I remember before
I went in and look in the mirror I'm so
stupid English I don't know myself and I
said followed you you say the most
difficult characters in in in the most
complicated movies tossed my hair a
little bit felt great can walk did my
bit and got the job
what's your message for viewers out
there about following the dream I would
say if you truly believe in something
and you really have a passion for
something didn't go for it I think
there's a lot of obstacle didn't have to
go through and if nothing's ever you
know given Q and
you really believe in it and so you
really have to believe the Internet's
going to be mainstream a lot of people
are going to get out there and use it
and that they're going to be willing to
pay for some content is that the
operating idea that you have well each
of these businesses is an
entrepreneurial business the
overreaching theme is that yes I believe
in the internet I believe it'll get
increasingly popular and we're doing
some neat new things to take advantage
of that you've got a lot of cash on hand
yes right all right
it puts you in an into a position you
can experiment with a lot of
entrepreneurial ideas and see what
sticks and what lies well we're in
business to make money and but the other
thing is providing such a cash flow for
you well it all belongs to the
shareholders
we're not dilettante oh I mean we are
businesspeople
and it is true that if you find an idea
that requires three or four years of
improvement and patience and really
sticking with it
that we're very good at that take
Windows which we bet our company on
everybody who doubted that would succeed
IBM did not support us in that it took
longer than we expected over four years
before finally graphical interface got
popular and now people take it for
granted it's part of every personal
computer and you just you just expect it
to be there that was one of the grand
successes of the company in the same way
we're betting on the internet that our
tools there will be popular and that a
few of these content plays that we've
decided to get involved in that the
scale and and the users will make those
in the great businesses thank you guys
so much for watching I'd love to know
what did you think of this video which
clip resonated the most with you and why
also is there anything that you want to
share but the power belief that will
help the other members of believe nation
leave it down the comments below and I'm
going to join in the discussion I also
want to give a quick chatter to Jerry
Crawford Jerry thank you so much for
picking up a cup of my book your one
word it really really really means a lot
to me and I hope you're enjoying it so
thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever you
one where it is much-loved I'll see you
soon